clyde game 61 ans en est à sa 3ème
tumeur au cerveau depuis 2013
il a tout essayé pour guérir
radiothérapie chimiothérapie et
chirurgie mais il a encore espoir de
s'en sortir grâce à un nouveau
traitement développé avec le virus de la
poliomyélite de tri matt formées réservé
à fait engueuler akanua il s'est fait
injecter au mois de mars le virus
modifiés de la polio dans le cerveau un
virus qui a pourtant tué des millions
personnes
il est maintenant utilisée pour détruire
le glioblastome une tumeur mortel qui
menace la vie de clyde est souvent mis
en avant
marco von ah ouais et ribéry evra barré
qui sourit il est au coeur d'un
ambitieux programme de recherche au duke
400e en caroline du nord
nous les avons suivis lui et ses
médecins qui développe ce traitement qui
suscite étonnement et incrédulité
la première patiente qu'on a à faire
le virus de la polio v
ça m'a dit je t'aime beaucoup d'acteurs
des jardins mais je pense que tu es
complètement folle l'oncologue
québécoise
annick desjardins dirige la recherche
clinique sur ce traitement depuis 2012
son collègue le docteur ennery friedman
directeur audio cancer' center n'y
croyaient pas non plus la food and drug
administration aux états unis
craignaient en effet que l'hôpital ne
déclenche une pandémie de polio en
manipulant le virus aujourd'hui le
docteur desjardins est encore renversé
par les résultats de la phase 1 ou 21
patients ont été traités
si je regarde avec le traitement de la
polio on a plus de 20% de nos patients
qui sont en toujours en vie trois quatre
cinq ans plus tôt il aurait dû mourir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une journée importante pour clyde
game
il est à l'hôpital pour subir une autre
résonance magnétique et toute une série
de tests
[Musique]
il va bientôt savoir si cette tumeur au
cerveau
traiter avec le virus de la polio a
diminué il attend avec impatience ces
résultats et le docteur annick
desjardins en compagnie de sa conjointe
et d'un de ses fils hereafter elder gods
cyclades peut encore espérer vivre
aujourd'hui c'est entre autres grâce au
travail du microbiologiste mathias
gromaire il a rendu le virus de la polio
sécuritaire pour traiter le cancer 20
ans de recherche et un peu de chance
pour en arriver à des résultats
étonnants
aujourd'hui le traitement fonctionne car
le virus de la poliomyélite transformé
par le docteur gromaire peut s'attacher
à la tumeur et fouettez le système
immunitaire
ce sont donc les anticorps du patient
qui font presque tout le travail
c'est ce que l'on appelle
l'immunothérapie tartiner d'art qu'est
ce que c'est le docteur desjardins a
deux bonnes nouvelles pour son patient
la lésion ici comme qui était très dense
très salée
à commencer donc quatre mois après le
traitement
la tumeur dans le cerveau de clyde
régresse le glioblastome pourrait bien
complètement disparaître d'ici quelques
mois
annick desjardins nous montre ici le
cerveau de sa toute première patiente
traitée avec le virus de la polio ce
qu'on peut voir maintenant cinq ans plus
tard la tumeur a disparu mais pas
seulement la nature a disparu mais aussi
la cavité chirurgicale le cerveau guéri
que vous venez de voir et celui de cette
jeune femme au début de la vingtaine
elle est en rémission depuis cinq ans
d'un cancer qui devait la tuer malgré
ces résultats spectaculaires les
spécialistes demeure prudent we believe
de créatures donc je regarde mes
patients en rémission et qu'il demande
demande qu'est ce que je dois faire
maintenant qu'est ce que je dois faire
ce qu est ce que je peux me marier
est-ce que je peux avoir des enfants et
et la réponse je sais pas il reste
encore beaucoup de tests effectués afin
d'espérer un jour commercialisé ce
traitement prometteur déjà le duke
cannes sur center essaie de traiter
d'autres types de cancers avec le virus
de la polio commençer la guerre contre
cette maladie ne sera probablement
jamais gagné mais chaque petite victoire
qui redonne espoir en est une qui peut
aussi parfois redonner la vie